[Musique]
je vous avoue que j'ai au moins trois
fois non avant d'accepter d'être là ce
soir parce que tout simplement j'ai peur
mais on m'a dit aussi que le courage
c'est accepter d'avoir peur alors je
vais prendre mon courage à deux mains et
je vais vous raconter ce combat
qui démarre effectivement je pense que
beaucoup d'entre vous connaissez
l'entreprise des entreprises
florissantes depuis plus de 40 ans et
on février 2020 on a commencé à avoir
des prémices alors on savait qu'il y
avait du coc vide mais on pensait pas
que on allait pouvoir être atteint à ce
point là et tout a commencé avec cette
histoire où je devais partir en voyage
début mars un voyage d'anniversaire de
mariage quelques trucs généralement qu
on prévoir un an à l'avancé et
on commence à avoir des appels de
traiteur de toute la france qui me
disent écoute là il ya vraiment un
problème on commence à avoir des
annulations de congrès des annulations
de réception de mai nous par chance dans
l'est on n'avait pas trop d'annulation
je me suis dit en plus tous et
l'entreprise familiale elle peut tourner
sans moi et donc tout était prêt les
valises j'ai même dit écoute remet moi
ce maillot de bain là parce que je
trouve que ça va bien aller avec le lieu
où on va et le lendemain on commence à
voir nous dans l'entreprise des
annulations
et ma soeur me dit écoute tu peux partir
nous on est là il ya pas de problème
mais j'avais quand même effectivement
une responsabilité nationale
et je n'avais un pressentiment qui
allait se passer quelque chose mais je
ne savais pas quoi et je ne savais pas
non plus combien de temps ça allait
durer
et du coup je suis rentré à la maison on
partait le 9 mars et je dis à mon épouse
je dis que je suis quand même un peu
inquiet
il ya quelque chose qui se trament je
sais pas quoi et elle me dit tout de
suite si c'est pour être stressé être
sur ton téléphone toute la journée
franchement on annule ça ça a été ma
première action de courage un peu ce que
je peux vous dire que j'ai quand même vu
la soupe un peu à la grimace
et mais je suis donc j'ai annulé ce
voyage et je suis resté et figurez vous
que le lendemain donc je partais le 9
mars le 10 mars on a un appel du cabinet
du ministre de l'économie et des
finances et qu'il dit voilà je veux vous
voir demain avec toute la branche
événementiel à paris à 11h du matin
heureusement que j'étais pas dans
l'avion et tout a démarré à partir de ce
moment là c'est à dire que j'ai
rencontré on était une dizaine de
personnes autour de la table du ministre
il y avait des chaînes tv et ça fait un
peu comme aujourd'hui si vous voulez
s'offre des églises sauf que je n'avais
jamais parlé à un ministre évidemment
puisque mon métier c'est de faire des
réceptions et c'est pas d'aller parler
dans les hautes sphères de l'état mais
je représente est une profession et
j'étais obligé de
remplir mon rôle et il me donne la
parole en premier
alors donc du coup je sais pas trop quoi
lui dire je lui d'écouter monsieur le
ministre on est dans la merde
et du coup ils m'ont
les chefs de cabinet mme ont un peu
repris en disant que j'avais un langage
un peu pathos et provinciales mais je
leur ai dit que j'avais pas fait
l'aller-retour quand même de lancer à
paris pour ne pas dire les choses avec
mes mots à moi c'est ce que j'ai fait et
il m'a dit écoutez je serai à vos côtés
et nous allons vous suivre jusqu'au bout
envoyez-moi les chiffres du réseau tous
les mois et c'est ce que nous avons fait
et
le combat après s'est amplifiée puisque
nous avons rencontré beaucoup de deux
chefs de cabinets de ministres etc pour
expliquer la détresse d'une profession
donc le courage pour moi ça a été déjà
ça c'était déjà d'affronter tout ça est
d'affronter un peu ce ce combat le
courage aussi
c'est d'oser
parce que vous comprenez bien pensée on
venait d'investir en plus à louvigny
avec un superbe établissement on avait
prévu l'avenir on avait dit que salle
est idéal pour la transition de notre
entreprise
elidel aussi pour continuer à
travailler sur la grande région
et tout s'arrête mais tout s'arrête
c'est à dire qu'au mois de mars 2020
tout s'est arrêté
l'entreprise a perdu 80% de son chiffre
d'affaires sur une année avec 70
collaborateurs et l'auto
le pire qu'on ait vécu en famille
puisque on travaille en famille c'est de
dire mais comment va expliquer à nos
collaborateurs de les mettre au chômage
partiel on ne sait pas ce que c'est que
le chômage partiel on a fait de la
croissance pendant toutes ces années et
on s'est aussi posé la question qu'est
ce qu'on allait faire et donc on a
on leur a demandé de déjà on n'a pas eu
le choix on a convoqué tout le monde on
leur a expliqué que la situation était
dramatique et que on leur a demandé de
créer des tutos en famille de recettes
que on a publié sur youtube sur facebook
et c'est pour montrer que on existait
montrer aussi qu'on était avec eux
on a également beaucoup écrit on leur a
écrit tous les mois on a fait des
courriers pour expliquer ce que ce qu'on
mettait en place le combat que je venais
au niveau national et leur dire que
voilà qu'ils aient confiance que on
allait s'en sortir parce que j'avais
fait une erreur c'était que je pensais
très honnêtement qu'en septembre 2020 je
vous rappelle mars 2020 toustou
reprenait normalement puisque les
resteront ouverts en mai juin et c'est
ce qu'on a essayé essayé d'expliquer
aussi au gouvernement c'est que c'est
pas parce qu'un restaurant il rouvre en
mai qu'un traiteur travail vous le savez
très bien il ya un délai de latence à
peu près trois quatre mois à vendre et
organiser un congrès et les mariages qui
avait été annulé ils sont pas dit
chouette marco tullio éprouvant va se
marier c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe donc il était obligé de d'avoir un
délai de un an et est c est en septembre
2020 tu
as tout c'est un deux nouveaux arrêtés
et en fait on a repris officiellement en
septembre 2021
est on est on a cru qu'on était sauvé
sauf que en décembre 2021 c'est à dire
là il ya pas longtemps une parole suffit
comme dirait enfin je sais but qu'il a
dit je crois que c'est jésus-christ mais
c'est pas grave
[Musique]
et le premier ministre annonce dans une
conférence de presse qu'il est
déconseillé
d'organiser des événements festifs en
entreprise bingo quinze des sens de
nouveau tout s'arrête avec plus du tout
de réception qui était bien repartie
avec plus de plus de voeux sur le mois
de janvier plus non plus de fêtes de fin
d'année pour les entreprises
et c'est
oser c'est aussi avoir fait des
entretiens individuels moi je les ai
faits on est 70 dans l'entreprise je les
ai fait un par un et je l'aurai toute
tous expliqué
ce qui se passe c'est la situation de
l'entreprise la situation financière les
réunions qu'on avait avec le pool
bancaire le
réunion qu'on avait aussi avec les
ministres etc j'aurais dit faites moi
confiance on va au combat je sais que ça
va être compliqué pour rebondir
faites moi confiance
on a fait zéro licenciement on a eu des
départs 10 qui sur 70 qui nous ont dit
écoutez moi je veux envie de changer de
vie c'est le moment ok d'accord mais on
a fait zéro licenciement à ça je suis
assez fier parce que c'est pas deux il
ya des entreprises où des chefs
d'entreprises qui sont plus des
calculateurs que des managers familiaux
comme comme notre entreprise qui se
disait il faut faire des licenciements
des groupes de neuf etc et tu verras un
chien et ses bas nous on n'a pas fait je
suis assez fier de ça parce que dans ma
tête il fallait garder les compétences
et les collaborateurs pour aller au bout
parce qu'on savait qu'on allait
reprendre
aux et
c'est également
les emmener avec nous dans ce nouveau
challenge et pour cela sept minutes il
me reste c'est ça ouais d'accord
c'est moi qui étais trop longs tout à
l'heure quand il a dit il faut animer
les choses donc c'est pour ça je fais
très attention
passé le moment
aux essais également
se réinventer et ça a été aussi une
forme de courage et quand il ya eu la
période de chômage partiel on est rentré
avec un fonds de formation qui
s'appelait le f et 2 et que l'état a mis
en place pour les collaborateurs qui
étaient tous au chômage partiel la
majorité de mes collègues ont
travaillé sur la formation de comment
améliorer ses petits fours la formation
sur la pâtisserie la fin de la formation
sur la cuisine et moi j'ai rencontré une
amie qui est consultante à metz et qui
me dit tu devrais plutôt les former à la
résilience la résilience et j'ai dit
mais c'est quoi ça la réunion se bouge
c'est même pas ce que c'était elle me
dit c'est l'art de naviguer dans les
tons à bages et tu peux y aller parce
que nous c'est pas des tendances et des
cascades donc il va falloir que vraiment
on trouve des solutions pour le faire et
on l'a fait et figurez vous que on a
informé l'ensemble de nos collaborateurs
à la résilience y compris nous est alors
je dois avoir une étoile au dessus de la
tête puisque le moment au moment où
démarre la formation de la résilience
chez une dame qui vient me voir et qui
me dit voilà je
fabrique des petits pots pour des
crèches et j'ai je vais construire un
nouveau laboratoire et j'aurai besoin d'
aide si vous pouvez m'aider jusqu'à la
fin décembre a fabriqué les des petits
pots je pense que si j'avais pas fait
cette formation sur la résilience et
amener mes collaborateurs a travaillé
sur le changement à travailler être
différent peut-être à changer de métier
je ne savais pas ce que ça allait
devenir dont je n'avancerai pas combien
de temps ça allait durer mais qu'est-ce
qu'on allait devenir si ça continuait
comme ça quand vous perdez 80 % de votre
chiffre d'affaires vous pouvez penser à
un moment donné que vous allez tomber
par terre
et donc on a fabriqué ces quatre 4 mille
fois par semaine de petits pois carottes
alors effectivement je suis passé du
foie gras aux petits pois carottes mais
mais au moins je sais faire maintenant
les qui voit carottes
je suis super dans les temps je suis
quand même super fier et ses quatre
minutes 52 c'est top
je vais quand même donc osé c'était
aussi parlé au ministre parce que j'ai
été reçu beaucoup beaucoup de fois comme
quoi mon langage pathos et provincial la
provinciale ça a bien fonctionné mais
même remis l'ordre du mérite donc vous
voyez que ça a bien fonctionné
c'était osé lui dire qu'on était dans la
merde je voulais dit mais oser lui dire
qu'on allait mourir osez aussi lui
parlait avec une voix tremblotante aux
mêmes sortir de son bureau où il est
venu me chercher dans le couloir en me
disant ne vous inquiétez pas je vais
vous aider parce qu'à un moment donné
avec toute la force et la rage la colère
aussi qui va animer est qui et qui
animait aussi mes équipes vie j'ai dit
mais c'est pas possible c'est 40 ans de
notre vie c'est 40 ans de sacrifices
parce que ce métier est un métier de
sacerdoce un métier où on travaille
quand vous vous amusez quand même tout
ça pour rien en fait tout s'est arrêté
du jour au lendemain et eu vraiment
alors je fais pas de politique mais ils
nous ont beaucoup aidés parce qu'ils
nous ont écoutés et c'est quand même
assez rare pour que je puisse le dire
aujourd'hui
enfin trois minutes 49 chefs
je vais
pour moi le courage il ya deux sortes de
courage il y a le courage que j'ai eue
avant comme idée ça c'est mon père qui
me l'a expliqué il m'a dit tu sais alain
pour être courageux il faut travailler
ceux là dessus pas de problème sans
relâche et pour moi être courageux
s'étaient travailler beaucoup c'était se
lever tôt c'était se coucher tard
c'était d'enchaîner les week-ends
c'était ne pas prendre de vacances
c'était ça le courage et c'était des
entrepreneurs c'est ce que nous avons
fait et qui fait que l'entreprise est là
aujourd'hui
après qu vide je vous avoue que ça nous
a permis un point et on a souvent pensé
arrêter j'ai 60 ans je me suis dit c'est
pas possible il ya quelque chose qui se
passe même le ministre m'avait dit mais
monsieur marco tu lui il existait des
solutions et vous déposer le bilan à la
barre du tribunal de commerce pour
acheter et je dis monsieur le ministre
ça fait une heure que je vous parle de
valeur
familiale entreprenariale et vous êtes
en train de me dire que c'est facile de
déposer deux de recommencer mais si hors
de question il m'a dit je m'attendais à
cette réponse tant mieux et donc on a pu
continuer notre combat est donc la préco
vite pour moi c'est l'avant covit très
courageux après qu vide c'est réfléchir
et on a beaucoup réfléchi on s'est remis
beaucoup en question avec ma famille
mais également mes collaborateurs on a
beaucoup travaillé et voyez quand il ya
eu la guerre en ukraine le début de la
guerre j'ai posé la question à mes
collaboratrices notamment une qui
s'occupe de la communication chez qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour on a pas on n'a pas
d'armes a donné on n'a pas d'argent
comment on peut aider ces gens à notre
façon et on a fait un arbre hameau des
arbres hameau dans l'entreprise et au
château d'ars sur meurthe qui est un
lieu qu'on nous nous gérons et nous
avons demandé à nos clients décrivent un
petit mot de paix et d'amour s'ils le
voulaient et de l'accrocher sur cet
arbre et le dimanche de pâques
on a fait on a pris ces mots et on les a
fait lire par les enfants de tous nos
collaborateurs des enfants qui vont de 2
ans à 10 ans ils ont lu ses mots et on a
fait une vidéo cette vidéo j'ai appelé
les cabinets que je connais bien
maintenant je leur ai dit voilà est-ce
que vous connaissez des idées des
associations chrétiennes pour que je
puisse envoyer ces mots d'espoir et ils
vont bien sûr donné des contacts j'ai
envoyé ces sévices cette vidéo appareil
25 ou 30 associations ukrainienne j'ai
eu des mercis mais c'est tout
et la semaine dernière on organise à
verdun au centre mondial de la paix le
dîner du club des chefs de cuisine des
chefs d'état et à ce moment là
par hasard je rencontre le chef
l'ukrainien et je lui ai dit écoutez ça
tombe bien alors je lui dis moi en
français et ma soeur traduisent en
anglais puisque moi l'anglais si vous
voulez c'est un peu limite
et on lui a traduit on lui a montré la
vidéo
il a pleuré eh bien vous savez quoi moi
aussi et c'est ça en fait le courage
c'est cdd un peu les autres à notre
façon mon monde à moi de président les
traiteurs de france s'arrête au mois de
novembre
et je vous assure que je vais pas
rempiler ça c'est certain parce que j'ai
pris dix ans en deux ans et mais je
continuerai à
donner de mon expérience parce que en
ces deux ans de co vite là j'ai beaucoup
plus appris on est devenu des sachant
qu'en 40 ans en fait de
professionnalisme coach ces 0,03
[Applaudissements]
merci